(upbeat music)
(cheering and clapping)
- So check out this
amazing video of a horse,
in Australia who's got impressive skills,
on the keys.
(horse playing piano)
(laughing)
(piano playing)
Love it!
Let's talk to this budding musician
along with his owner, Sophie.
(audience shouting)
Hi Sophie?
(Sophie laughing)
Oh my gosh, first of all...
Holy
(beep)
I was like, she looks
exactly like Patty Griffin!
(screaming)
(audience laughing and clapping)
(audience laughing drowns out speaker)
- Oh my gosh
- I think the horse is good
(beep)
- Wait did you see my face?
I was so confused, I was like,
that looks like Patty griffin.
Oh my God! I love you so much!
- Hi Kelly.
Congratulations on your second season,
of your really cool show.
I've been watching.
- I'm going to cry right now.
You're the nicest human ever.
Like I named one of my
dressing rooms after you.
- Write on
- Like Patty, I'm crazy.
I know every inflection, like every,
I'm just singing burgundy
shoes right now, man.
I love you so much. I think
that you saying no to,
I even have a,
a tattoo I'm like that are
not fan that comes to see
me at shows. I have a tattoo of a kite.
I love the kite. I sing it to
my children row every night.
Since they were babies,
and it's the saddest song in the world.
You probably shouldn't
sing that to children,
but I do anyway.
And I think it's,
cause it sounds like a lullaby,
and you have the most perfect voice.
And you were like,
my goal in life is to write one
song that is half as good as
what you write.
And you're so great.
And anyway,
we've been talking about
though, how music heals?
Have you been working on anything new?
Asking for a friend
- I'm plugging away? Yeah.
It's, been a tricky times.
I think here's some people
it's super productive and other
people I'm in the group of
kind of confused right now,
but I'm plugging away.
You just gotta show up,
do the work and something will,
turn up eventually.
Right?
- Well,
I mean a lot of people plug
away Patty and they show up and
they don't and it doesn't end
up sounding like what you do.
So, thank you so much.
This just made my day.
I had a really crappy morning for real,
and this just made my day
So thank you so much.
And you're wearing my
favorite color green.
I love everything about you.
Anyway,
I can't wait for your music.
- Let's hang out.
Don't you threaten me with a good time.